you end up hiding certain elements of
your i'm going to tell you a story that
happened then all right
and this is why i changed my behavior
because so i forgot to tell you so jamie
the first launch we had right there's
another actor named cheyenne jackson
that's also in the movie right very
talented guy
handsome can dancing do it all right so
jamie goes
let's go but let's walk to the river
so this is where i threw in my
personality and it backfired oh boy so i
go so we were walking along this
neighborhood no oh okay worse okay so
there's like eight of us
and along this river
along the side are these bronze
shoes
stuck on that you know the edge part of
the
there's a
hood rose of it right and i guess back
during the holocaust
oh god yeah the nazis came in
and they just lined up jewish people
and they shot killed them and threw them
into the river it's not going to a good
place
already
right
so um
cheyenne jackson goes
she he sees little shoes
right and everyone kind of
gathers around
the little shoes
and he goes oh my god
a little boy and people are like
emotional
so i go
it could have been a [ __ ]
nobody laughed no not it worse
they all collectively turned around
and walked away
so i'm now just with by the shoes you're
awesome
my head's down like it's the first day
it's the first [ __ ] day dude
so i'm not my head is down looking at
the shoes and just in my head you know
you go through the thing
like dude why did you do that
this is not a bunch of comedians you
mean this is your gut is wrong
you cannot do that again right so the
whole trip there were so many instances
where i wanted to [ __ ] throw out a
banger
right and i just
my filter went no
stop
you know
so after that you didn't do anything so
i had to hide
an aspect of my [ __ ] personality
did you ever think of saying sorry about
the [ __ ] no i never even brought it up
i pretended as if it never happened
oh god i know it was terrible and then
in fact i think cheyenne jackson
right
i think he
he was very nice right
but i could tell that maybe it was in my
own head but like because i said that
joke he couldn't get that close to me
but then like when i first when he was
there in my first scene and i did well
then after that
it kind of
resolved itself right who did you act
with
did you act with cate blanchett no no i
had one scene with her but it was it was
almost i get
i get um
tazed
right right and then i fall on my back
and then
kate blanchett and kevin hart have a
scene
over my body and you have to just lie
there first and i'm laying there so i
guess that's a scene sure yeah yeah
you're the tased guy i'm the tails guy
did were you astonished by kate's acting
amazed
i'm just amazed by like just sitting
there like there was one scene where um
gina gershon had a big monologue kind of
thing to say and just and i'm reverse i
have no line but i'm in the scene
and i'm just dancing in there and
watching
it you know because it's like
you know the shows that i do which i i
love the shows i do i've done i've been
on sitcoms and i've been on um i mean
sometimes i do magnum pi some of these
shows
and it's like the energy
and the i think the
the level is completely different you
know
it's like you know when you do tv and
you know this is you feel like there's a
sense of urgency because it's like they
have yeah they have to move on you know
i mean it's like
you do a couple takes they're like
that's fine let's just move on you know
even though like i want a different
another tag
but with with you know films as you know
as well is is that they let things
breathe there's more time a lot more
shooting there's more shooting more
angles more
you know there's more discussions about
the scene whereas like the director will
go
yeah just the tone and the energy i
think you know i mean probably just slow
down whatever it might be you know i
mean it's like a different vibe you know
so it's like
you just want to
you just want to learn how to do all of
it i guess